حرب المسيرات اضحت الوجه البارزه للمواجهه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه كل طرف يسعى الاستهداف
عاصمه الاخر بعدها هجمات متواصله على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه هجوم جديد استهدف
موسكو بالمسيرات فرضيتان اثنتان بخصوص
الهجوم الاوكراني الفرضيه الاولى تتمثل في
استهداف موسكو انطلاقا من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه خاصه وهي منطقه تبعد عن موسكو
حوالي 600 كيلومتر الفرضيه الثانيه تشير
الى تنفيذ الهجمات من داخل الاراضي
الروسيه ما يعني وجود خلايا نائمه داخل
التراب الروسي خبراء اشار الى ان الطرفين
يمتلكان مسيرات دواره وذات الجناح الثابت
والانتحاريه ابرز المسيرات التي تمتلكها
كياف طائره اوكرانيه الصنع يبلغ طول
جناحها اثنتين وثلاثين قدما وتستطيع
الطيران لسبع ساعات وتصل سرعتها الى 100
ميلي بالساعه واخرى امريكيه الصنع لمده ست
ساعات بسرعه 100 ميل في الساعه فضلا عن
المسيرات التركيه الصنع برقدار من طراز تي
بي اثنان والتي يبلغ طولها سته امتار ونصف
تحمل اربع ذخائر موجهه بالليزر روسيا هي
الاخرى اضحت متقدمه مؤخرا في تصنيع
الطائرات المسيره ثابته الجناح كطائرات
اوريان التي يبلغ طولها 14 مترا وتستطيع
الطيران لمده 24 ساعه متواصله بسرعه 120
ميلا بالساعه اضافه الى المسيرات ايرانيه
الصنع التي تبلغ سرعتها
185 كيلومترا بالساعه وهي كبيره الحجم لكن
صنعها منخفض الكلفه تبلغ هدفها بواسطه
احداثيات نظام جي بي اس يتم ادخالها قبل
اقلاعها وتحلق بعدها في شكل ذاتي على علو
منخفض تصل هدفها الثابته بالضروره على بعد
بضع مئات الكيلومترات بلال الوجد اني
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات